A
TRICK TO TRY TO WIN POWER FOR
THEMSELVES.
AND IF YOU CAN TELL ME WHAT
THEIR PLANS ARE FOR THE FUTURE,
I WOULD SHARE LOVE TO HEAR
THEM.
>> I HAVE TO ASK YOU ABOUT
SOMETHING THAT YOU SAID EARLIER
THIS WEEK, LET'S ROLL THAT
SOUNDBITE.
>> LET'S NOT PRETEND FOR A
MINUTE THAT BOTH SIDES HAVE THE
SAME AMOUNT OF ACCOUNTABILITY
FOR THE LOSS OF COMPETENCE IN
OUR ELECTIONS.
ONE SIDE HAS BEEN OUT THERE FOR
A COUPLE OF YEARS NOW DOING
EVERYTHING THEY CAN TO PRETEND
JOE BIDEN DIDN'T WIN FAIR AND
SQUARE.
>> THE THING IS, DEMOCRATS
SPEND $53 MILLION SUPPORTING
FAR RIGHT CANDIDATES, ELECTION
DENIERS IN THE PRIMARIES.
INCLUDING THE DCCC.
BY AMPLIFYING THESE ELECTION
DENIERS, AREN'T YOU HOLDING
RESPONSIBILITY TO A DEGREE FOR
THE UNDERMINING OF DEMOCRACY
THAT YOU ARE ALSO WARNING ABOUT?
>> OH MY GOD!
JAKE, LET'S BE REALLY CLEAR,
THAT CLIP YOU JUST PLAYED, IT
WAS WHO IS QUESTIONING THE
OUTCOME OF ELECTIONS.
THAT STARTED WITH DONALD TRUMP,
AND WE ALL KNOW IT.
LET'S BE CLEAR, THAT $53
MILLION, IT IS $400,000 AT THE
DCCC AND ONE RACE, ONE, WHERE
WE RAN A TRUE, GENERAL ELECTION
AD TWO WEEKS EARLY, CALLING
JOHN GIBBS AN EXTREMIST WHO IS
TOO CONSERVATIVE FOR --
>> IT IS A BOOSTER.
>> AND HILLARY, WHO IS A GREAT
CANDIDATE, IS GOING TO BEAT HIM
LIKE A DRUM.
SO IF YOU WANT TO ASK THE
PEOPLE WHO SPENT ALL THAT OTHER
MONEY, THAT IS GREAT.
LET'S BE CLEAR, NOT ONE TIME
WAS SPENT FROM THE DCCC
SUPPORTING ANY REPUBLICAN.
IT WAS SPENT CRITICIZING A
REPUBLICAN FOR BEING TOO
EXTREME, AND IT IS GOING TO
RESULT IN A PRO-CHOICE, STRONG
CANDIDATE NAMED HILLARY'S
COLTON WINNING THAT RACE.
>> COME ON, YOU GUYS WERE
BOOSTING JOHN GIBBS, AN
ELECTION DENIER, A MAGA
REPUBLICAN SO THAT HE WOULD
BEAT CONGRESSMAN PETER MEIJER,
WHO VOTED TO IMPEACH DONALD
TRUMP AFTER THE CAPITOL
ATTACKS.
YOU SAW GIBBS WOULD BE EASIER
FOR YOUR DEMOCRATIC CANDIDATE
TO BEAT, SO YOU BOOSTED HIM.
THAT IS THE ONLY REASON THAT HE
WON THAT RACE!
>> YOU ARE USING THAT WORD
BOOST TO BE KIND OF CUTE.
OTHER PEOPLE SAY THAT WE ARE
FUNDING THEIR CAMPAIGNS.
IT IS RIDICULOUS.
WE ARE ATTACKING THEM, BUT WE
ARE ABSOLUTELY RIGHT, WE
THOUGHT HE WAS AN EASIER
CANDIDATE, AND HE HAS PROVEN TO
BE.
BECAUSE HE IS A NUT.
HE IS TOO CONSERVATIVE FOR
WESTERN MICHIGAN, AND HILLARY'S
COLTON IS GETTING READY TO BEAT
HIM, AND THAT IS MY FOCUS.
MAKING SURE THAT WE BRING
COMMON SENSE DEMOCRATS TO
CONGRESS WHO ARE GOING TO MOVE
OUR COUNTRY FORWARD, AND LET'S
BE CLEAR, AGAIN, $400,000 OUT
OF A 340 MILLION DOLLAR BUDGET,
SO IF YOU WANT TO WARM UP THESE
LEFTOVERS WE CAN KEEP GOING.
BUT WE HAVE GOT FIVE OR SIX
DAYS UNTIL WE HAVE AN ELECTION,
AND THAT IS WHERE MY FOCUS IS,
AND WE ARE GOING TO WIN THAT
SEAT IN MICHIGAN.
>> THAT $400,000 FOR JOHN GIBBS
DID BOOST HIM AND HE BEAT
CONGRESSMAN PETER MEIJER, PETER
MEIJER WHO DID SOMETHING BRAVER
THAN I HAVE SEEN IN TERMS OF
MOST MEMBERS OF CONGRESS, IN
TERMS OF BUCKING HIS PARTY TO
BE ONE OF TEN REPUBLICANS TO
IMPEACH DONALD TRUMP.
WHEN PEOPLE LIKE YOU SAY WE ARE
ALL THE GOOD REPUBLICANS, TO
HELP DEFEAT ONE OF THEM!
>> JAKE, LET'S BE CLEAR, IF
YOUR POINT IS THAT I SHOULD, IN
SOME SORT OF EXERCISE OF
DEFEATISM, STOP TRYING TO BEAT
REPUBLICANS IN VULNERABLE SEATS,
WE ARE GOING TO VOTE FOR KEVIN
MCCARTHY, AND PUT JIM JORDAN AT
THE HEAD OF THE JUDICIARY
COMMITTEE, WHERE THEY ARE GOING
TO TAKE AWAY YOUR REPRODUCTIVE
FREEDOM, PASS A NATIONAL BAN ON
ABORTION, GIVE YOU TWO YEARS OF
HUNTER BIDEN AND NOTHING ELSE.
IF YOUR POINT IS THAT I SHOULD
ROLL OVER, PULL A BUNCH OF
PUNCHES, AND MAKE SOMEONE IN
THE MEDIA FEEL BETTER BECAUSE
WHAT?
WE HOPE THAT SOME OF THESE
DEMOCRATS WILL BE NICE TO US?
HOW ABOUT WE ELECT SOME PEOPLE
WHO ARE ACTUALLY GOOD ON ISSUES
LIKE CHOICE, OR GUN SAFETY, OR
ON SUPPORTING LEADERS WHO WON'T
SUPPORT AN INSURRECTION, AND
PETER MEIJER WAS GOING TO VOTE
FOR THE MAJORITY THAT ON
JANUARY 6TH VOTED TO SET ASIDE
THE ELECTION.
AND THAT IS A DISTRICT THAT JOE
BIDEN WON WITH 56% OF THE VOTE,
AND WE ARE GOING TO WIN IT.
AND I HAVE SAID, I MEAN IT,
THERE ARE DIFFICULT, MORAL, AND
PHILOSOPHICAL QUESTIONS AND
POLITICS.
YOU BETTER BELIEVE IT.
BUT LET'S BE VERY CLEAR, THIS
IS $400,000 AND THE BUDGET OF
300 MILLION, ONE RACE, ONE, AND
THE ENTIRE CYCLE WHERE WE RAN A
GENERAL ELECTION AD THAT WAS
PERFECTLY TRUE, CALLING THE GUY
AN EXTREMIST, AND HILLARY'S
GOLDEN IS GOING TO WIN.